hello Sandra my name is Juliana Rotich a
little with shamini on twitter is at
opera music and the organization's
Twitter account is at osha heidi and
your question is what am i doing
specifically to invest in innovation and
job creation as part of lucia he d we
are part of the founding team behind
that i have narrow be and you can follow
at I habanero be I have never miss a
co-working space that brings together
technology enthusiast in Nairobi Kenya
and brings them together in a space
where they can collaborate and work
together to build new companies and in
future that will actually create jobs
within Kenya and just to mention that we
are part of the innovation ecosystem in
Africa and around the world so thank you
for your question and let me know if the
you need more information and just
follow as i know i have had I habanero
be and also a dilution Haiti thank you